um in the case of the that's no
different than the dark arts battle
arena that's also true of the combat
Arena but uh but uh one of the things
that we're excited about in the dark
arts battle Reno that people can do is
is you come in pre-loaded with different
abilities so uh the unforgivable curses
are something that everyone's going to
have access to through the base game and
going to be able to earn and they can
make choices in order to kind of like
add that to the repertoire and they can
also commit to that down with certain
talents and things like that when you
when you play the dark arts combat Arena
you actually have access to all those
things as kind of like a way to test
them all and so it's a chance to kind of
like tour and play with the dark arts
and decide whether or not that is a path
that you kind of want to go down and
again a great place for us to show off
combat in general uh so I think we're
gonna jump in here Andrew's gonna start
just start battling and we can start
talking about everything you're seeing
on the screen all right
[Music]
oh my God that's so cool yeah so that
you'll you'll notice right away like
when we use Avada Kedavra that guy's how
far went from instant to zero and we
really are trying to honor the way Avada
cadaver works in the game even in some
pretty extreme situations
um you'll notice that like the the meter
takes up a lot longer to yeah kind of
build up as a way to kind of deal with
its extreme power just that it's still
fun to use and then there's some some
ways that we'll probably talk about to
to to adjust that but I don't know I I
don't know if there are things on the
screen that you just have questions
about well like I see like little blue
things
from the enemies also before like that
sign well it's like so in the community
we call it the ancient magic sign I
don't know if that's how it's cold yeah
in the game so the community is asleep
so on the development side and player
facing in the game we reference that as
your ancient magic
it is ancient magic that is yeah so as
your as your abilities in the game keep
growing and you become exposed to some
of the secrets about your own kind of
history and your own your own abilities
um you start unlocking new powers so one
of those Powers you'll see the R1 button
appearing uh throughout the game uh
that's an ancient magic throw we call it
that allows you to kind of like draw an
object to you and fling it at an enemy
um okay but whenever you see the R1 or
the L1 plus R1 up here over somebody's
head that's an ability to cast a very
devastating and Powerful ancient magic
spell to do a ton of damage against the
characters and the way that manifests
itself uh depends on the type of enemy
that you're fighting and you'll see a
wide variety of enemies in here that are
pressuring the player in different ways
you'll notice there's there's uh
abilities that kind of bubble up under
the player as it's fighting that forcing
to move and there's different ways that
we want the player to kind of move
around on the battlefield and that's
actually a good link to the intermagic
leader in general and the reason why I
say that is because as you're doing
different things in combat you're
protegoing and you're doing different
abilities and kind of spectrum through
with your talents there are different
ways to get that meter to build faster
and faster but one of the most effective
base ways to build up that meter fast
that way you can launch these
devastating attacks whenever you want to
is is to actually perform combos so you
see that combo it's almost like your
your emotions are building up and then
basically that built up enough that you
can attack someone but as the combo
meter builds up at some point you strike
someone and a piece of their magic kind
of falls out of them you'll see the blue
orbs in in the in the game world and
there's something that only you can see
in in the narrative in the world and
it's another reason to move around on
the battlefield if you can build up and
collect those things and suck them in
they give big big jumps to that ancient
magic meter as we're playing we're
talking a lot about about spells and
Magic here but I think there's another
huge component of combat and that is the
the tools that you can bring to combat
as well to kind of uh change the way you
play and I think Mackenzie knows a lot
about what's going on with the plants
and potions and so the the tools are
really interesting because they're
basically like a prior investment so you
can bring the potions and the plants
that you grow in the room of requirement
to combat to essentially kind of help
you defeat enemies a lot quicker and
more efficiently so some of the tools
that you'll see here are like the rock
Skin Potion so that is something that
basically covers your skin in this like
Rocky material that
reduces the incoming damage that you're
receiving so against big enemies
hard-hitting enemies like trolls that's
super helpful
um oh my God she's just destroying the
troll just collapsed from whatever the
kiddos obviously we have the Wicked
Wheel potion as well which increases
your health and then we have the bogus
potion so when Alan talks about having
to balance Avada Kadabra with a long
cool down because obviously it's an
instant fill one thing that you could do
is brew a focus potion and that will
increase how quickly your your cooldowns
regain right
there's just so much like a versatility
like what the character is doing to the
troll right now like he's just bouncing
around around the arena he's like nuts
and the troll makes him move around too
looks like and I love that our plants
are violent yes and so that's like when
we're talking about the almost the setup
of the Arena you also have plants that
you can fight with and so we have things
like the venomous tentacula that you
could put down and it acts like a turret
and it just kind of shoots enemies
around the battlefield that is so cool
this is like a truly like hufflepuffian
way to approach the battle
no that was super important to us but
there were things like multiple ways and
so you can see there's there's a ton of
different things you can use uh the
Mandrake is one so you can pull it out
and it stuns with its like piercing
cries enemies uh in a radius another
thing I want to call out uh that we're
seeing on the side of the screen here is
these these dueling Feats which I love
because I love anything that prompts me
to play a game in a different way a
unique way I don't want to get stuck in
my style you know know uh and and so
this is a way to if you want to get
stuck in your style go for it if you
just want to blast people with spells go
for it but we also want to uh have some
things over here that may make you use
certain plants or certain potions or
block more or yeah we mentioned the
field guide challenges
um uh in the prior stream and the field
guide challenge is this is the way that
the field guide manifests like
challenges for you to do and exactly to
your point
um we just wanted a way to encourage
players to to explore the different
systems to help them decide to just kind
of practice with them and explore what
they want to be because there really are
so many different ways that you can push
talents when you see the the green x's
on characters that's right and that's
kind of uh through your talents you can
unlock this kind of cursing mechanic
that sort of like links the fates of
these different characters on the
battlefield that way as you get the as
you're cursing different characters they
all begin sharing damage and so we have
things like Avada kadaver which is the
insta kill but if you curse everyone
before you insta kill this one guy they
can all drop dead for that kind of
ultimate
and so oh my god there are there are
dark ice fantasies there's fantasies
about being more of a defense against
the dark arts character things like that
that Misty step that you see um
occasionally being used on the
battlefield and we can also spec into
our potions and plants to make them more
powerful and more efficacious so it's
all about which type of player you feel
like you are and whether or not you want
to play with prep on the fly or with
deliberation and those are all different
options that is so cool because they get
like I see so much like going on on the
things of so much complexity and I I
want to just try it myself like which
style works best I mean I feel like it's
the Dark Horse is going to be the
easiest
ancient magic to be honest feels like
much more powerful than just the dark
Hearts yeah and speak